[Musique]
des Landes de pierre autour
ne soyez pas pressé c'est pour les
vivants c'est pas pour toi Daniel un peu
d'enfer on est trop pressé le Connemara
[Musique]
nuage noir qui viennent du nord colore
la terre les lacs les rivières c'est le
décor du Connemara
était en pleinement
ils sont arrivés dans le comté du
Connemara
[Musique]
tout le prix du silence
la
vie
[Applaudissements]
mais la folie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
belle Africa
où vont les eaux bleus tout le monde tu
t'engages
[Musique]
ton cœur s'en va attention
tu peux des oiseaux
et brûlant des filles par sado pas de
mes doigts
à l'incroyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu t'engages
mon cœur s'en bat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'anniversaire de Michel
Sardou
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable
ah c'est bien c'est mieux
c'est bon là c'est dégueulasse allez
merci Nico merci Nico heureusement toi
qui est mort
tu pourrais pas laisser pousser un peu
les favoris ça pourrait faire joli
[Musique]
quand je changeais de sexe
que je vivais l'étrange drame
d'être une femme
femme des années 80 mais pas me jusqu'au
bout ayant réussi la bagarre de
l'autorité du chat
qui va du grand sourire là le trampoline
ou
être
humain
à la fois
directeur de cabinet à la 68 les femmes
chirurgiens et ses véhicules le
maîtresse métallique mais quand
le matin les abattoirs et dans la soirée
notre gloire
l'aviation pour les dégâts mais non
[Applaudissements]
être un agent de promotion par marcelage
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
[Applaudissements]
il fait que du yaourt
on dirait Chirac avec les joueurs de
l'équipe de France
mais c'est vrai que c'est un amour en
plus alors attention
c'est parti météo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on fait la java le samedi à Broadway ça
fume comme un melon
on défend sur les va pas besoin de
Beaujolais quand on a du bobo
la Java
mais oui c'est ça elle qui pleure quand
on est favorer on se tire déborder sur
la 49e
[Musique]
des
Oscars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui remarquait comme une barque malade
c'est la meilleure c'est la merde
[Musique]
sous les sabots du
cheveu
et mon chéri d'amour
[Musique]
des sirènes ambulance aux vitres
aveuglées
déchiré le silence à travers les fumées
sans faire de jazz
il me
voit chanteur de jazz
[Musique]
dans le River Café au pied du pont de
Brooklyn buvez d'anciennes Maryline de
vieilles femmes
pour
[Musique]
ce qui est
Alexandre
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la reprise faudrait remettre dans le
River Café
[Applaudissements]
comme ça dans le River chacun votre tour
[Musique]
dans leur univers café
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la maladie d'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle court elle court la maladie d'amour
dans le cœur des enfants de cette à 70
ans
elle chante elle chante la rivière
insolent
qui unit dans son lit les cheveux blonds
les cheveux gris
[Musique]
et s'agrandir le monde
c'est parfois
tout le long d'une vie
[Musique]
mais le plus douloureux c'est quand on
dort
elle court elle court mais quoi la
maçonnerie
où ça dans le cœur des enfants de cet à
77 ans
elle chante elle chante la rivière
insolent qui unit dans son lit les
cheveux longs les cheveux gris oh merci
[Musique]
est-ce que vous voulez serrer il y en a
une qui est très fort
[Musique]
magnifique
j'avais fait une parodie sur ça ah oui
je vais pété
c'est mon premier spectacle avec
Jean-Luc Lemoine que j'envoie Jean-Luc
ils s'en souvient voilà allez-y mettez
je vais t'aimer le début est fou et tu
as raison France ne m'appelez plus
il est parti trop vite
[Rires]
comme ça Michelin
normalement
elle est jolie d'ailleurs avec cette
guitare
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors à mon avis ils ont coupé l'endroit
parce que je pense qu'on a jusqu'à 19h30
[Musique]
maintenant pas encore
je pense qu'on va écouter l'intro
magnifique
[Musique]
par contre
attention ça va arriver bientôt
c'est vrai
[Musique]
ah ouais
face à tous les échos
[Musique]
je vais t'aimer Daniel
c'est là on l'aime bien mes cours
c'est bon c'est bon on l'a vu
ah attention attention je vais faire un
lancement un gars si je vous dis quand
j'étais petit garçon
vous me dites
[Musique]
quand je t'aime petit garçon je repasse
et mes leçons
en chantant
et bien des années plus tard je chassais
mes idées noires comment en chantant
c'est beaucoup moins inquiétant de
parler du mauvais temps
en chantant
et c'est beaucoup plus mignon de se
faire traiter de con comment en chanson
la vie c'est plus marrant c'est moi
désespérant en chantant
la première fille de ma vie quand j'ai
vu je l'ai suivi
en chantant
j'étais si content de moi que j'ai fait
l'amour 10 fois
en chantant
mais je ne peux pas m'expliquer comment
elle décédé
enchanté
l'amour c'est plus marrant c'est moi des
espérant en chantant j'attends une
phrase préférée tous les autres à la
pêche
en chantant attention la fleur au bout
du fusil la victoire se gagne aussi
en chantant
on ne parle à Jéhovah à Jupiter Abouda
quand j'entends c'est bon
quel que soit nos opinions on fait ça
révolution
en chanson
ça fait du bien
[Applaudissements]